I like playing those like 1300 seat
theaters like those that you I know
you've been know I do 50 2500 or 250
[Laughter]
keep your pants on
remember uh the Spaghetti Factory Oh
Mike Bobby factory story oh really yeah
yeah
why used to how's yours well you came
right who's there
uh the only person I really remember
being there is you your brother and Ari
Shaffir Shaffir yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and uh because I think he I thought he
was funny then yeah I think he's so
funny now so funny now this is before he
beat the [ __ ] out of me or after did you
guys ever make up yeah okay he called me
out of the blue that's nice yeah if you
guys don't know this a lot of people do
Ari Shaffir beat the [ __ ] out of me
wrong the point where I was bleeding
anyway because he just got tired of your
stuff or well no no because of Natasha
Leggero Oh what happened I'm gonna just
tell you the quick story okay um when I
was on mad
do you remember Ron Peterson Canadian
guy well I was at the Comedy Store one
night and he goes who's that on stage I
go that's Natasha Leggero she's hot I
could yeah but she lives with Ari
Shaffir Ron Petersen goes alright and
then I walked away because I did another
show in the main room whenever and then
a couple hours later I was driving him
back to the hotel where he was staying
and he goes I got her number
yeah but he's seeing she's seeing my
friend Ari there's a gap but she's gonna
go on so she starts like going to like
plays with him dinners behind his back
right and then out of nowhere or he
calls me she left me dude okay yeah but
you could you stack them up right I
didn't set them up because you dad
and here's how I know you you did it
how if you don't do this for me right
now this thing I want to ask you to do I
know that you said to mom whoa what was
it that was the thing great show him
your penis I know you do that that's
free yeah that's a Korean break into
something break into his office the guy
TV yeah go into his computer and steal
the emails between Ron so I go I can't
break into his [ __ ] office at MADtv
but can I just say the wise you will
love you with a little smoke smoke bombs
okay that smoke puffs smoke okay still
want to correct you I'm not and um so I
go I'm not gonna do that
and he goes didn't you set them up so
that Friday I show up at the Comedy
Store and I'm checking in at the front
counter and he punches me in the face
like for real punches this is not a
comedy fine comedy joke fight I fall to
the ground
and he kicks me in the face like 20
times [ __ ] no bleeding I'm bleeding I'm
like you know almost you know coma but
then as I get up I hear my name being
called on stage by stage and I go up on
stage and did I talk about it or I only
did I only went up for one minute yeah
and I go that guy right there
you don't mean I'm bleeding from the
face like I called him my ear right then
I get offstage and the battery goes just
I mean he's just emotional I do anything
I know all right
how cool I am yeah a week later I'm
walking down the hallway at the Comedy
Store
[ __ ] right and he starts strangling
me in the [ __ ] hallway with this
little Jew thumbs in my throat and I
don't mean that in a racist way just
descriptive yeah but I'm just saying
that that's how I thought at the
beginning the back dad and he's
squeezing and then he my neck starts
bleeding because he has his nails gouge
into my [ __ ] neck why it's so funny
baby
what is so then and then I remember I
was dating a comic back then and she was
doing a show upstairs Sara did she come
to your rescue no she didn't
but I remember going upstairs and my
neck is bleeding and she goes why are
you crying and why is your neck oh right
I bet that was a turn-on to her I was
the beginning of the end
yeah sure then the worst thing happened
so then unbeknownst to me this is when
mind of Mencia was going on okay okay
Ari Shaffir had auditioned for mine and
Mencia and gotten the part when Carlos
Mencia was out of town so we had Edition
for the producers they had hired him but
then when Mesilla caught back in the
town he already knew that Ari had
attacked me twice and he was looking at
like who was performing you know on a
show and he saw Ari on it yeah so he
called Ari Shaffir and said hey dude um
you beat up my friend Bobby so you can't
do my show so in all his mind he thought
that I had calls oh no here comes the
third yeah yeah this is a real bad
sequence yeah I'm so glad I didn't get
ever I would have beat your ass so then
I show up at the Comedy Store after he
gets fired from mind of Mencia and I
just hear running right like I parked
the car I close the door I hear we up
above and then no running because he's
in the air in the Superman play superman
patch from behind pop i fall to the
ground right i just run straight to the
office screaming right I've worked for
this guy yeah
I try I try to call 9-1-1 what i call
9-1-1 to call the police right I answer
the phone and then nothing do you know
why Steve Rannazzisi had pulled the
[ __ ] cord on the [ __ ] wall and he
gets on his hands and knees and he goes
if you call the cops now
he's gonna be in jail all weekend cuz it
was a Friday I go home I just went home
and then the next thing I know he got
banned from the club and then for three
or four years after that every time I
would walk by him he would call me a
piece of [ __ ] and I wanted to say I
didn't do anything and but you guys have
finally patched this up I'm so sorry I
asked this our mansion then out of
nowhere he calls me and he just goes
this is five years later hey dude it's
alright and I just wanted to go [ __ ] you
right but he goes I know that you had
nothing to do with that you know I was
just emotional I love you were you a
little worried like a fist was going to
come yeah and also you're trembling
because I've I loved him mm-hmm he was
my friend
[Music]